15:47 and king henry the eighth is dead
his son the nine-year-old edward was
crowned king edward the sick he was too
young to govern the kingdom on his own
and so a Regency council was established
to govern for him this was led by his
uncle Edward Seymour the duke of
somerset somerset essentially ruled
alone he continued the anti papal
policies of Henry and even went a bit
further most notably by introducing the
English language into church services
these changes were extremely divisive
and upset the Catholics because they
went too far and upset the Protestants
because they didn't go far enough a new
prayer book was created in its use made
mandatory by the act of uniformity these
religious changes coupled with the
booming population and economic woes led
to riots it should also be noted that
England was still at war with France and
Scotland at this point and so Somerset
levied heavy taxes to support these
which led to revolts in 1549 one such
revolt was led by Robert ket a butcher
who sought to redistribute wealth from
the rich to the poor another riot was in
Cornwall which at this point didn't want
the English language which many there
did not speak forced into their churches
Somerset eventually crushed these
revolts but he was shortly afterwards
removed from office by John Dudley the
Earl of Warwick or it quickly ended the
wars with France and Scotland in a 1551
he granted himself a new title the Duke
of Northumberland King Edward influenced
by the reformist Archbishop of
Canterbury Thomas Cranmer reformed
church services further by removing more
Catholic elements in a second prayer
book was released to replace the first
in 1552 Edward caught measles then a
fever and then tuberculosis and it was
pretty clear that he was going to die
soon
Cranmer told the king that his
half-sisters Mary and Elizabeth weren't
really Protestant enough and so should
be barred from succeeding him Edward
selected Lady Jane Grey to succeed him
where she kind of did when Edward died
in July 1553 support for her claim died
pretty quickly Edward's eldest
half-sister mary launched a coup only
nine days later Jane was thrown in
prison and Northumberland who some was
married to her was convicted of treason
and beheaded Mary was crowned Mary the
first and importantly was a firm
Catholic which is why she threw Thomas
Cranmer into prison for heresy many were
unhappy with the woman being in charge
and so she sought to strengthen her
position by marrying philippe Habsburg
the heir to the Spanish crown and all of
these lands this worried Parliament who
didn't want to be part of the Habsburg
Empire so it was decided that Philippe's
power came exclusively from his marriage
and that he held none in his own right
that said Mary often asked for and
followed his advice meaning he had a
great deal of power anyway and he was
certainly active in the running of the
realm many of England's councils
regularly briefed Philippe some official
documents were written in Spanish and
Philippe also sorted the defence of
Calais in England from French and
Scottish threats of course Philippe er
Mary's primary concern was that of
heresy in Protestant resistance Mary
wanted to return England to the Catholic
world an appointed Reginald pole as the
Archbishop of Canterbury to help Mary
and Paul began a series of persecutions
against Protestants which saw just under
300 people being burned at the stake for
heresy the most notable being the former
Archbishop himself Thomas Cranmer these
acts of suppression would be the reason
why Mary is nowadays known as Bloody
Mary Mary managed to get Parliament to
repeal most of the religious laws
enacted under her father and
brother-in-law an archbishop poll sought
to bring in England back into the
Catholic fold beyond this the Crown's
finances were repaired but a lot of this
came from Philippe simply importing lots
of Spanish silver from the new world
marrying Philippe also oversaw the
plantations of Ireland which were when
native Irish were removed from their
lands and it was given to the English to
settle and run this was because Ireland
had been slowly drifting away from
English control with many of its leaders
only paying lip service the idea was
that by removing the Irish from their
land and replacing them with loyal
Englishmen eventually Ireland would
become as integrated as Wales was Mary
and Philippe were hoping for a son and
Mary had what is known as a phantom
pregnancy whereby she showed the
symptoms of being with child but you
know without the child this subset
Philippe who left to become the king of
Spain and to make matters worse for Mary
famine which killed about 5% of the
English population Phillipe returned to
England in 1557 bearing good news by
which I mean war with France this war
was expensive unpopular and ultimately
disaster and ended with the loss of
Calais in 1558
Mary would have another phantom
pregnancy before dying in November of
the same year she was succeeded by her
half-sister who was crowned Elizabeth
the first Elizabeth was assisted by her
close friend and advisor Sir William
Cecil who was a loyal and gifted
statesman who helped her settle into a
role as Queen Elizabeth had inherited a
religiously divided Kingdom and a first
acts were to reverse the reunion with
Rome which led to the passing of the
second act of Supremacy in 1559
Elizabeth was actually a moderate
Protestant who was willing to tolerate
certain Catholic acts but the zealot ory
of the Protestants around her may towing
this line difficult the religious
settlement was sorted by 1563 with the
creation of the thirty-nine articles
which laid the doctrinal foundations for
the Church of England
Matthew Parker was a
pointed as the Archbishop of Canterbury
and many of the exiled Protestants began
to return to England the settlement
didn't just upset the Catholics but also
another group the Puritans the Puritans
believed that church reform hadn't gone
far enough and tried to petition the
Queen for change but she refused it was
not just religion that plagued
Elizabeth's early reign but that of the
succession notably who she would marry
this issue became much more pressing in
1560 when Mary the Queen of Scots
returned to Scotland from France Mary
was a relative of the powerful French
family the geeses and also a descent
defended the seventh and so had a claim
to the throne in the money to back up
that claim she was also a Catholic and
thus could persuade some of the
population to help her remove the
Protestant Elizabeth if Elizabeth could
get married and have a son though it
would be harder for her to press that
claim Elizabeth as she tended to be was
slow to decide on a course of action and
refused to be rushed in her early reign
she was infatuated with a man called
Robert Dudley and there was talk of a
marriage except for one small issue he
was already married his wife ended up a
little bit dead but in the end Elizabeth
chose not to marry him
ultimately Elizabeth would never marry
though and often used her eligibility to
suit diplomatic ends in 1567 Mary Queen
of Scots fell out with the Scottish
nobility and was imprisoned and forced
to abdicate leaving her son James to
take the throne she escaped to England
the next year but sessile advised
Elizabeth to put her under house arrest
in 1569 there was a major Catholic
rebellion in the north many of whom
sought to put Mary on the throne sessile
crushed this revolt but the problem of
rebellious Catholics wouldn't go away
since in 1570 the Pope declared that
Elizabeth was an illegitimate Queen a
heretic in the Catholics and obey her
the latest sixteenth century saw
relations between Protestants and
Catholics deteriorate massively and saw
the outbreak at the French Wars of
Religion and the Dutch Revolt Elizabeth
gave some help to the Dutch which along
with the English raiding Spanish
treasure ships angered king philip ii
who wanted this to stop the result was
war in 1585 which was mostly just
raiding for the first couple of years
concerns over Catholics rebelling and
aiding Mary take the throne later
sessile having her beheaded which
angered Elizabeth Elizabeth brought the
neutrality of Scotland in this war with
a lot of money and also hinting that
James would succeed her as the King of
England in 1588 Philip who also
controlled Portugal sought to deal with
England by launching a great Armada
which was supposed to rendezvous here
with the large Spanish force and
transport them to England an English
fleet led by Lord Howard met the Spanish
here at the Battle of Gravelines the
English make greater use of cannon to
prevent it the Spanish
learning which forced the Armada to
return to Spain by going around the
British Isles the Armada was wracked by
storms and disease and limped back to
Spain a shadow of its former self the
next year Elizabeth ordered Sir Francis
Drake to launch a counter-attack to free
Portugal and destroyed the Spanish fleet
to put it mildly this counter Armada was
a catastrophe and led to most of the
English ships being sunk and many
sailors dying from disease oops
Elizabeth's reign wasn't told religion
and war though and her rules for great
innovations in art and architecture art
such as port restore many changes with
Elizabeth being depicted many times for
special emphasis being placed on her
virginity piety in in her later years on
portraying her still as young writers
such as Edmund Spenser make greater
artistic use of the English language and
his most famous work the fairy queen was
so well liked by Elizabeth that she
granted him a pension for life of course
the most famous writer of the age was
not Spencer but a certain William
Shakespeare Shakespeare outlived
Elizabeth but some of his most famous
works were created in her reign such as
Romeo and Juliet The Merchant of Venice
in A Midsummer Night's Dream he was not
the only popular playwright of the age
though Christopher Marlowe was another
so the war with Spain continued onwards
for the rest of the 16th century
England's role was mostly financing his
continental allies and preventing the
Spanish from landing in Ireland in which
Elizabeth was continuing the plantations
this time in the hope of increasing the
loyalty of the south which was where the
enemy would most likely land as she aged
Elizabeth started to take a back seat in
the affairs of the realm the war against
Spain was run by her ministers mostly
Robert Cecil the son of William who had
died in 1598 the church was run by John
Whitgift the Archbishop of Canterbury
who shared Elizabeth's dislike of
Puritans a made sure to suppress them
England also saw harvest failures in
1596 and seven which saw Parliament
enacting Glyn's first pour relief
schemes which would stand until the 19th
century
another important long-standing creation
of the Elizabethan age was the East
India Company which was founded in 1600
and given a monopoly on trade with the
East Indies furthermore the late 16th
century also saw a major rebellion in
Ireland led by Hugh O'Neill the Earl of
Tyrone this nine-year rebellion was the
most serious threat to the English
reestablishing control over Ireland and
at first the Irish were very successful
the most notable victory being the
Battle of the yellow Ford here the Irish
were given assistance by the Spanish and
Elizabeth appointed Charles Blount the
Baron Mount joy to crush the revolt in
the end the English were able to commit
greater resources and defeated the Irish
Nobles driving them out and opening the
gate to further plantations
Tyrone's rebellion as it's known
importantly marks one of the last
the Irish could effectively resist
English rule and their loss broke the
power of the Gaelic nobility which had a
pronounced effect on Irish culture of
course the great issue of Elizabeth's
reign was the succession she never
married and made no attempt to nominate
a successor and so when she died in 1603
the throne went to someone who was
related Protestant and male this man was
King James the sixth of Scotland who was
proclaimed James the first of England
and Ireland the accession of James the
first at the end of the House of Tudor
in England in the beginning there of the
House of Stuart Elizabeth's reign had
many important legacies but arguably the
most important is that her reign
Spedding than the immense turmoil and
violence that shook the rest of Europe
during the later sixteenth century
she is best remembered for her
resilience during the war with Spain but
remembered that the Armada was destroyed
not during a battle but during a storm
it was also worth noting that
Elizabeth's primary duty was to secure
the succession which she failed to do
and it was fortunate that no one
challenged James his claim and plunged
England into a civil war I hope you
enjoyed this episode and thank you for
watching there are some book
recommendations in the description below
if you'd like to know more
you